l'euro made in france dominique strauss
kahn n'était pas mécontent ce matin
d'être le premier ministre des finances
a appuyé sur le bouton et les machines
maintenant tourner à plein régime pour
stéphanie père ed et bien d'autres et on
appuie sur l utilité première pièce de
15 euros nous fait oublier dès 2002 et
dominique strauss kahn qui a déclenché
la prade taillé à 13h le bo est enfin
devenu réalité fait d'avoir entre les
mains aujourd'hui le premier au complet
euros et ciments français prend voir
dans la poche a historic prix à oui y'a
pas de problème
ce rappel france comme très riche en
émotions aussi des êtres sous-employés
de lusine vient monnaie le franc frappé
25 ans est progressivement abandonné des
tac tourner une page de son histoire
pendant trois ans il va falloir
multiplier les cadences par 3 est
fabriquée près de 8 milliards d'euros
soit 12 vidéos par jour
pour cela des du jamais vu depuis 20 ans
voit des personnes ont été refusées
mais certains ne veulent pas ça va les
trouver à faire entre deux arrêts après
elle va être attendent en 2002 la
priorité c'est la sécurité
le mot est placée sous très haute
surveillance pas question de nous et et
sortir la mode body piette avant le jour
j
christian bruit mais c'est correct pour
être fait par des gens malveillants et
bien sûr après avoir mis fin rapidement
à ce projet et pilleurs de pierre trois
fois le poids de la tour eiffel il va
falloir les stocker pendant quatre ans
et là le problème n'est pas encore tout
à fait réglé mais le secret sera très
bien